- What's upstairs?
Some toys up there
when I was a kid.
FRANK FRITZ: Coming in!
Coming in hot.
FRANK FRITZ: Coming in hot!
Coming in hot!
[interposing voices]
All you had to do is say toys.
BRUCE: This is my
old room over here.
MIKE WOLFE: Yee-ha!
- Wow.
Look at all these--
oh man!
MIKE WOLFE: Holy cow!
Man--
Super score!
MIKE WOLFE (VOICEOVER):
We get upstairs,
and there is stuff everywhere.
There's toys in boxes.
I don't know which way to look.
This was one of
my favorite games
when I was a kid, Spirograph.
- Spirograph.
Spirograph!
Oh my god, was
that my favorite.
FRANK FRITZ (VOICEOVER):
I can remember
opening up my first
Spirograph for Christmas.
I didn't know what it was.
My grandma helped me.
You put the pins in the gear.
You could put different
gears in, the big ones,
the small ones.
BRUCE: And that would
make a different design
inside of the design.
FRANK FRITZ: You could
make just about anything.
Next thing you
know, I'm an artist.
[interposing voices]
MIKE WOLFE: Oh, look at that!
FRANK FRITZ: It looks like
you never even played with.
BRUCE: Never played with.
Well, I played with that.
I evidently just
kept putting it back.
FRANK FRITZ: You kept
it in great shape.
Man, that's very unusual--
FRANK FRITZ: I mean,
look at the designs.
--for a boy.
BRUCE: All the pieces
were still there.
I think that was something
that I learned from my dad
with tools, that once
you get a project done,
you put things away.
So the next time you want to
use it, they're all still there.
29 bucks.
Oh, what's this?
FRANK FRITZ: Etch A Sketch.
You remember that toy?
Boy, man, did I
have the fun on this!
MIKE WOLFE: I'm telling you.
- Some people were so good.
MIKE WOLFE: Is it working?
Yeah, it's working.
BRUCE: I remember playing
with that an awful lot, just
amazed at what
drawings and things
that you could come up with.
Ohio Art made this.
This was popular '70s.
Yeah.
It's in the original box.
Some people were
so good at these.
They used to have competitions.
MIKE WOLFE: Look at that.
20 bucks.
I'll go with that.
Good deal.
I love it.
MIKE WOLFE: Look at that!
Spudsie!
- Yeah, you wind it up--
- I don't think I remember that.
- --and you throw it around--
- It's like hot potato?
It's like the hot potato.
BRUCE: There was
another one there.
So you just toss it
until it friggin' blows up?
Yeah.
Till it blows up.
There's still time.
Yeah, it's still going.
It usually needs
a little WD-40.
[alarm rings]
Dude, you blew up!
MIKE WOLFE: Bruce played
with these things,
but then he learned
to put them away.
$25.
- Good.
- All right.
MIKE WOLFE: Look at that!
'63-'64 Corvette, SS Camaro.
FRANK FRITZ: Yep!
MIKE WOLFE: Anything that
Chevrolet would have put
their name on-- oh
look at this, they even
put Chevy on the racetrack.
This actually had the
Chevy bow tie on it.
You opened it up and it had the
Chevy dealership on the track.
"See the USA in your Chevrolet."
I can kind of
remember getting that,
but I was getting a
little bit older in age.
Who needed the toy cars?
I was actually driving
the real things.
It was never even
played with, Bruce!
Man, your dad must have
had you really out there
friggin' working on
the farm, you never
even played-- look at this!
FRANK FRITZ: Original batteries!
MIKE WOLFE: They're
not even screwed up!
$30.
You gotta go more on that.
Give me a number.
$50 on that.
$50.
I appreciate it.
Holy cow, Bruce.
Wow!
Man, you got the
cobwebs down here, whoa!
[squealing] Look at this, whoa!
FRANK FRITZ: There you go.
I'm set!
Watch out-- ooh, yeah.
Look, they got like little
circles in them, Frank.
FRANK FRITZ: That is a
whole city right there, man.
MIKE WOLFE: Yeah,
can you imagine
the spiders that are in here?
Made you a little space.
MIKE WOLFE: What?
FRANK FRITZ: Made
you a little space.
Aren't you thinking about
where are the spiders are?
Holy cow!
FRANK FRITZ: Yeah!